[Music]
additional watt McGraw tecnico PETA new
yes a red Capricia aqua nest Oh a red
co-ed in honest fair to toss velu this
fetish a land a probe a very good
Moyes level and CSer consortium severed
magnetic neck
[Music]
sixteen years ago Slobodan see mesh
bought a dozen donkeys his herd has
since grown to nearly 300 but hundreds
of donkeys doesn't necessarily mean
gallons of donkey milk
unlike cows or goats donkeys produce
milk in very small quantities while
nursing their fall all of the other says
a PETA was a shto he named a sea route
margaret a craig videos in the tonico
news for the president so we try to make
cheese from his donkey milk but it turns
out that process was far from simple
problems problem see you tomorrow a
Gracie a con named adobo no kazarina
coleslaw Jesus gross nominee Malaika so
he keeps his methods a secret not readin
do go tram process poet Roger
Oh drezna tiny Shah Bano dresnok
problema que droga Luda miseration
Toya Oh Nostromo Gujarati sir good
analogy in high school
Mitra notice melody Nikko is nom on a
private a sailor Democratic leg the
cheese goes for around $500 a pound and
it has a rich nutty and earthy flavor it
is known to be quite filling but just a
select few have tasted it you can only
get donkey cheese in Serbia in a posto
any cocoa a proba or dionisio diatone
esta rosa la cañada sinestro's joy a
poor seven oh yes Tony man a druggie
mastema the original rubbish no
predominant school
[Applause]
be quick to God
you know how middle typically sorry
Marcy me Nicola mother midnight in their
unit he wouldn't risk it all you know I
looked it and I got to see my sister
this she was good team us silly ho six
to London I made him to the unbiased
Amos one Paku Paku you don't sing
holiday Humberstone was Sir Horsa go up
he won't Iggy my owner can issue it's
good to attacks on disc at all
so naga demo kappa Denis she looked a
okie Sunnyview night with what I see
greatness to our games other states
could be masane Hibernia that the
Kennedy music asiento not a guinea to 92
to pursue more they can I see series -
ah he looks looks clever school or cuts
to the console a kiss Kimani occur to me
that this - no they say Heaney
nirupa la Juventud and hippies man
Tropico can I do end up with my loss
you know karate sighs domani total
balance the ADA serious
ASIMO rip Anatomy was Toretto and
O'Conner
Oh Kafka wanna impact or an indicator to
the shekinah can see they will see
difficulty
[Music]
co-hosted a squad meet a more Q&A series
ago to build a cannon to go to see also
Canada Dakota giving us all of the Kenai
as a colony such the katashi de la Motte
big dick you know you could utter
seducing her cheek and Achilles
[Music]
yeah mrs. Tucker ah you see what a
Pocono kudamon over I think I seen toka
I might occur what she took up okay
sandy did I come at you I'm a second I -
you are a mother
nice name
campus revs percent that is little to
move Nathan Bakken organ began della mia
kun-hee terms of particular ragi semiya
hitam nama saya we rocked Zuma
saya the tournament money the Indonesia
[Music]
buggy or anthem Amulya I am too many to
DSF to pass Takagi yeah doc - Thomas I
am Eliot Ness I attacked you black agate
kanessa jacket it was knocked out and I
am it was
I am Hitomi to actually stopping at a
bloom panna cotta moon but Ursula
device' sciatica see the fatigue our
guitar I hate Amon but I am - Malini
karna melanin pigment pigment melanin
Aman wat da Lang on what I am me -
bergna then could be her melanin
paladinous I am teaming image and I can
America when JD I am young sanity Tom
[Music]
Harvey I am Germany - variety program
Coppola equalities
sakaram Duga Hagana circuit are so cool
oh sabado Goethe I am great bagus walk
on demand and boom OH katana is a jack
rod buggy for me likhna or octopod Nia
this boot sebagai paneer here venomous a
bad car Nikita ,
study companion mystic the I am in the
be my monkey terminology Hoban and
chemistry
- boom on young antara baton and I am
Capitola get stressed like we sake like
in Guyana Bagheera and another I am need
to go to stress Yamaha allocate a nice
man yeah I am India bloody sire maou
button I am - Nani Alaska thought the
Bhangra then watch I forgave again
amnesia an arrest warrant granular
Piazza now as you say I am the top close
focus DILG man
[Music]
it can be beetles that come off a cactus
it can be the dried urine of a cow
little insects that grow on an oak tree
a chunk of lead that's soaked in vinegar
it's truly amazing
we're in Harvard University outside the
shorts pigment collection pigment is a
very small particle of colored material
that is mixed in with a binding medium
the pigment gives paint its color the
forced pigment collection has been
brought together over several decades we
have around 2,500 pigments we have a lot
of very unusual and very rare colors so
that this is I think one of the more
unusually named pigments it's called
dragon's blood it doesn't come from
dragons it comes from rattan palms and
it gives a very bright red pigment the
unusual aspect of mummy has to do with
its source rather than the color itself
and that comes from Egyptian mummies and
it's the resin that's applied to the
outside of the bandages I think the
rarest color that we have is actually a
an entire ball of Indian yellow and this
is a pigment that is made from the dried
urine of cows that are fed only on mango
leaves
if you're looking at a work of art and
you want to understand what is original
and what's a restoration you will take a
tiny sample of pigment and analyze it a
lot of the pigments are actually toxic
so you don't want to handle the pigments
and then go out to lunch
there's a green called emerald green
that has an arsenic center to it we can
use them for telling if something is
real or not people will say this is by a
certain artist and we can look at the
materials that are used and decide if
those materials were available during
that long artists lifetime if not then
we have to look at who might have
painted that picture I can't pick a
personal favorite there it's like asking
to pick a favorite child no the other
2400 would feel left out
[Music]
bioluminescence is the scintillating
effect of a living thing emitting light
and in a small coastal town in central
Japan one glowing creature is also a
delicacy
[Music]
trauma Bay is around 4000 feet deep one
of the deepest bays in all of Japan and
home to one of the only commonly edible
bioluminescent species in the world
música de todas Jota Ricardo use this
regional an engine with a mask a door
operated in a sympathic in a Colorado
Firefly squid fishing is an a normal
fishing job they have to fish in the
dead of night
bioluminescent sea creatures prefer the
dark depths of the ocean but the Firefly
squid lights of the shores when they
spawn making them easier to catch
Johanna chose their needs in Oahu one of
them manage their Jim Bo steamers sorry
Carla Santini the only possible Oh it'll
be the Keowee Zara Bajirao hiding desk
at all
irony Sam that was our papa you only
have our Papa hiding us where is all
that squid going well to places like
capillo rocky a small Japanese
restaurant an american autonomous
singapore and hong dude you know
itemizes paparika noses are you possibly
have a rare Adriana so you had scarce
turkey massive ramekin rhetorical mummy
you know our rotary camera is named
Hamato c'mon go amok they all see we
don't go yo for can life fits with the
orders history muscle chef Iraqis menu
includes multiple variants of Firefly
squid from salted to grilled boiled to
sashimi all of them delicious and most
importantly
fresh ass out here ooh your daughter
stays on the most famous
you
[Music]